-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Of course...
the big thing
that's most exciting
is we have the Super Bowl set.
It is the Kansas City Chiefs
against the San Francisco 49ers.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Okay, and...
interesting wrinkle,
first year...
Las Vegas.
First year we're doing it
in Las Vegas.
It's gonna be
a little different.
Uh, prostitutes are, um...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Are offering
the Travis Kelce special.
-It's, uh...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
For an extra 50,
you can score
in their tight end.
It's, uh...
-(AUDIENCE GROANING, APPLAUDING)
-I know, it's terrible.
Oh! (MUMBLES INDISTINCTLY)
But here's the great story
of the week,
and it's about the Super Bowl,
and it just shows--
I mean, the Right Wing,
they are just mental.
-Like, I can't even...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
They have
a conspiracy theory now...
(CHUCKLES)
...that this whole game--
the whole thing is rigged.
Okay, that the romance
between Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce
was engineered by the Pentagon,
it's a psycho-op operation
-A psy--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Yeah, psycho-op
is exactly what it is.
Psy-op operation.
Uh, and the NFL is in on it.
The whole season is rigged
so that they could be
in the Super Bowl.
And then at the Super Bowl,
Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift
at halftime will endorse Biden.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Well...
all I have to say
about this is abort!
-They're on to us!
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
You know.
Really? That's what it is?
That this whole romance
was engineered
to throw an election?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Or maybe just the popular girl
is dating the football player.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-You know. Uh...
And look,
I think Taylor Swift is great,
all respect
for what she's achieved,
but this is so high school,
is it not? I mean, just...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
(MIMICS VALLEY GIRL)
My boyfriend's
a football player, and...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(SCOFFS) ...I wear his jacket
with his number
to the game and...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
He's gonna be prom king
and we're gonna make
fetch happen again.
-I mean, fucking...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Okay. But...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But it has driven them...
It has driven
the Right Wing--
I mean, Fox News,
they have outdone themselves.
I mean, it's--
Fox News. These guys amaze me.
Everything with them
is always a plot.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-So, it's always a...
it's always a conspiracy.
Yeah, except the time people
actually stormed the Capitol...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...on the very day
they were certifying the votes.
-That was just spontaneous fun.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But this thing,
they are worked up
about this like
I can't tell you.
I mean, they even think
that they can criticize,
they're doing this on Fox News,
Taylor Swift for flying
on a private jet
because it's bad for the--
The CO2.
That's how irrational
Taylor Swift has these people.
They're worrying
about climate change
-and rooting for San Francisco.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)